choosing the perfect actor for a movie
role is already a delicate process but
it becomes even more difficult when an
actor leaves a production which can
happen for any number of reasons
directors and casting professionals can
be left scrambling to replace their
departing stars here are some of the
craziest last-minute replacements we've
seen on the big screen some of which
ended up being the replacement actor his
most successful role Mike Myers and
Shrek it's hard to imagine anything but
Mike Myers voice coming from the lovable
animated ogre but the story of Shrek's
casting is actually quite tragic
originally comedian and character actor
Chris Farley had been cast in the role
and according to his brother Kevin
Farley actually completed recording
nearly all of his dialogue for the
original shrek film people see me and
they go unfortunately Farley had been
struggling for some time with alcohol
and substance abuse and in December 1997
he passed away in his Chicago apartment
after an accidental drug overdose
DreamWorks rushed to find a replacement
and chose Myers
additionally they recast the role of
Fiona with Cameron Diaz who replaced
Farley's SNL castmate Janeane Garofalo
Christian Bale and American Psycho in an
odd turn of events Christian Bale ended
up replacing himself for the role of
Patrick Bateman in the 2000 black comedy
horror film American Psycho well sort of
director mary harron had chosen Bale for
the role but the British actor wasn't
yet the superstar he is today executives
at Lionsgate wanted a higher profile
actor and reportedly made a 20 million
dollar offer to Leonardo DiCaprio
without informing Heron Heron fought
hard to keep bail but Lionsgate
eventually removed her from the project
- replacing her with Oliver Stone Stone
began revising the script and the film
fell into a period of developmental
he'll eventually DiCaprio left to film
the beach and stone walked out as well
when Lionsgate finally came back to
Heron she agreed to return his director
with bail as Bateman their perseverance
definitely paid off as the film became a
polarizing box-office success an
eventual cult classic helping propel
Bale to the top of Hollywood's a-list
Wow
there's unless a coincidence Hugh
Jackman in x-men although he ended up
landing the role of Wolverine in x-men
Hugh Jackman wasn't director Bryan
Singer's first choice originally singer
won at Russell Crowe who turned it down
Crowe recommended his friend Jackman for
the part but singer decided to go with
the more experienced actor Dougray Scott
unfortunately for Scott production on
Mission Impossible 2 was delayed leaving
him unavailable when filming for x-men
began forced to make a last-minute
change in the main cast singer called in
Jackman for an audition gave him the
role in the rest is history
Geena Davis and a league of their own
with her performance as Dottie Hinson in
the 1992 sports drama D a league of
their own Geena Davis won the hearts of
moviegoers everywhere however director
penny Marshall's original choice was
actress Debra Winger who was furious
when she learned that marshal and cast
pops superstar Madonna in the film
Marshall later recalled in her memoir
that before walking off the set winger
told her you're making an Elvis film
subsequently Davis nailed her audition
in Marshall's backyard and proved that
she could throw a ball while the rest of
the cast have been training together for
months prior to filming Davis had to
work hard and fast to get into shape for
the demanding role Michael Biehn and
aliens it's probably hard to picture
anyone but Michael Biehn is Dwayne Hicks
of the 1986 movie aliens but originally
it was supposed to be James remar
however a couple of weeks after filming
started remar abruptly left the
production he later revealed during a
sidebar podcast interview that while he
had originally cited urgent matters at
home to explain his departure the truth
is that he was struggling with drug
addiction at the time and director James
Cameron fired Rima after he was arrested
for possession with no time to prepare
for the physically demanding role
Michael Biehn was brought in as remar
placement head Harris in The Truman Show
the critically acclaimed satirical film
The Truman Show wouldn't be the same
without the character Christoph the
obsessive showrunner played masterfully
by Ed Harris but director Peter Weir
didn't choose Harris at first originally
Dennis Hopper was cast in the role after
filming began we're and hopper
reportedly ran into creative differences
on the set leading hopper to leave the
production entirely hopper later
revealed that he was fired after only
two days of filming
and he called a major blow at the time
called up at the last minute to replace
hopper Harris threw himself into the
role earning himself an Oscar nomination
and a Golden Globe win for Best
Supporting Actor Clint Eastwood in Dirty
Harry in addition to his performance as
the man with no name Clint Eastwood is
also frequently remembered for his
portrayal of the hardest nails homicide
cop Harry Callahan and Dirty Harry but
the role almost went to another famous
performer Frank Sinatra supposedly the
script written for Sinatra had Harry
toting a 12-gauge shotgun as his
signature weapon but his production got
under way Sinatra had to back out a
broken hand he sustained while filming a
fight scene for The Manchurian Candidate
left him unable to hold a gun after
ensuring the original script would be
used Eastwood agreed to play Harry
cementing his place in pop culture
history with a 44 Magnum and the
frequently misquoted line you've got to
ask yourself one question do I feel
lucky
what do you [ __ ] thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]